[Music]
magnus carlson team okay
well mr magnus girls and team let's play
e4
let's play a4 he's on his team
well this is a monocle s moment c5
all right so we've been playing c3
sicilian
pretty much not pretty much exclusively
on the uh
five minute speed run but uh let's go
for a topical let's go for open sicilian
let's go for a topical line just in the
spirit of the candidates
yeah well hopefully it plays a poison
pawn let's uh let's see if we can get
the fabulon
yeah i'm playing open sicilian which is
d4 that's the main line obviously open
sicilian
um and uh yeah 94.
well he's playing into it so far whoa
coder with a 20 damn girl
that was insane all of a sudden the 20
coming in
hot from coder what is
that that's crazy
that is an ultimate poggers moment oh my
god
i had to disable the alerts thank you
for the 20 coder i really appreciate it
distracting me from the speed and i
couldn't do that earlier just getting
over 6 000 that's awesome okay
now this move most people who play the
open sicilian will not have seen this is
called the cotton hour variation
it's not particularly good now
those of you who played the night or
with any kind of regularity know that e5
itself is a common idea so the
idea itself is not that bad but there's
a very specific reason
why you play a6 and then you play e5
and that reason is what
what is available so b5 is available you
might assume that we want to go knight
b5 but
we don't because knight b5 black goes a6
and the knight has to go to a3
yeah so it's not knight b5
which doesn't leave us with much of a
choice it is actually bishop
b5 now what is the purpose of this check
the bottom line is that we are trying to
get the f5 square for our knight
to get the f5 script for now we either
have to trade the bishops which will
happen after bishop d7 or
if he would have played knight b to d7
that bishop would have been obstructed
so that's the entire reason you have to
play a6 when you play the knight or
now we take the bishop and then we go
knight to f5 we have a beautiful square
for a knight there is theory in this
line black is not losing or anything
some people have played this and there's
a certain amount of theory here
but black is worse black is worse
because this knight is amazingly placed
the pawn on d6 is under fire and black
is
hardly able to breathe well if they go
to g6 we take the pawn also g6 is pretty
weakening so we might see that in the
game
okay so queen b6
now we don't need to do anything about
the possibility of g6 because it weakens
his king side and we got to think about
where this knight could go
if it were attacked by the pawn so who
can offer to me a pathway for this
knight were
black to play g6 why aren't we why are
we not afraid of g6
where is the knight going to go
so h6 is possible but unnecessary if you
think about
the weak squares right d5 is the biggest
weakness of black's position
so just on a positional level we want to
go e3 and knight t5 and if black
like in the night or when white is able
to do this white's
in great shape so we can just castle we
don't have to
do anything about this threat he's
probably going to go g6
and then we go 93 knight d5 establishing
the knight on a beautiful outpost
it goes rook to d8 instead okay
now um we have a poison pawn
situation here where the queen ties us
down to the
two pawn but that's already a mistake in
reasoning
thinking that oh we have to play rook b1
i think i would see a lot of people here
go rook b1 or b3
and that would not be a terrible move
that would there would be some sense to
that but we actually don't have to do
that
the bottom line here is we are so
overwhelmingly ahead in development
and so active that we can
not just get away with sacrificing the
pawn but if black takes it
black is going to be in a lot more
trouble than if he doesn't so
on that note if we if this bond were to
be no concern
what would we do here what move what
active developing move could you offer
okay so bishop e3 attacks the queen and
encourages
it to take the pawn but i would argue
that there's a more active move a lot of
you
i've said this before are attracted to a
move because it creates a threat and
that's
legitimate to a degree but remember that
we want the e3 square to be sort of
reserved
potentially for the knight and that
bishop on e3 apart from attacking the
queen is not going to be doing much but
the bishop on g5 is going to be pinning
the knight
and it's going to be paving the way
potentially for knight to d5
uh given that black can't move this
night the rook will hang
this is a much more active square he
takes immediately thinking that he's
hot s-h-i-t but watch what happens to
him so
what do we what do we do there's many
good moves
there's many ways to play this we need
to recognize that our knight hangs
and the simplest is of course to play
knight to d5 and centralize the knight
using this pin now hilariously
if he takes the knight we can take his
rook but
i don't think we should i think that we
should keep our eyes on the greater
price of just giving checkmate his king
is in such trouble
that taking the rook believe it or not
leads to unwanted complications what
move
can you guys spot after bishop takes
rook
that complicates the game unnecessarily
black has an intermediate move if you
look very carefully
this knight on d5 will be hanging but
that knight will be able to move to c3
and attack our queen and if our queen
moves well then the king will be able to
take the bishop we'll probably be fine
there
no no but you guys are looking for white
i was asking for black
i was asking after bishop takes d8 find
black's intermediate move the response
to that is knight to c3
so we don't need to reinvent the wheel
here we simply keep the tension with
queen takes d5
threatening his rook and threatening the
d6 spawn
now uh it's time for us to collect the
harvest what do we do
now it's time for us to move in for the
kill
yeah check he's got to take we take we
threaten checkmate
there's only one way to stop checkmate
without giving stuff up okay now he
starts thinking when his move is forced
he has to play f6 now in such positions
when you're looking for maiden stuff
you have to always consider the drawback
of your opponent's move when you're
about to defend against the threat and
his king is as weak as it is
the the quickest shortcut to finding the
correct move is to ask yourself what
squares are no longer defended
you know what as a result of his last
move we can no longer go queen e7 but
what can we now do
which which was impossible previously
now some of you are considering rookie
to d1 that's a good move
but it is much better to first force the
king onto d8
right it can't go to f8 because we take
the knight and attack the rook at the
same time
and after king to da rook 81 is going to
be a lot stronger because it's going to
pin this knight and threaten checkmate
boom obviously if he takes the bishop we
take his knight and that's me
so he's just probably going to go rook
c7 and then we have a
very nice uh move on top of that
so the attack is okay he plays correctly
queen b5
that's i'm pretty impressed actually all
right
now we need to consider uh you know we
need to look at the candidate moves just
be methodical
it's the game is not over yet we have to
be accurate
now a lot of you are calculating bishop
takes f6 so let's calculate bishop takes
f6 gf6
queen takes f6 he can't take the queen
because of the pin
so you might conclude that you win the
rook but
if you look a little bit more carefully
you will notice that he
has king c7 and the rooks connect we're
not able to take the rook
so instead we should look at other ways
to involve more pieces in the attack
okay so you might come up with the idea
let's double our rooks
but a slow move like rook d3 might not
be
fast enough because he takes the bishop
but as coder indicates rook to d5
circumvents that problem because it
occurs with tempo
you guys might say okay rogue d7 queen
d7 didn't work because
because rook d the d1 square is
undefended okay now we go rook d1 of
course
doubling our rooks and his knight is
toast now he has to go rook c7
to which we can of course respond then
bishop takes f6
so the tempe are important and you might
say well isn't it lucky that you
just happen to have this move rook t5
well that's just what happens when
you're attacking
now let's try to be accurate rook takes
c7
absolutely possible completely winning
but the king escapes to b8 and we're
gonna have to finish him off there
is there anything that we can start with
which perhaps
eases our task do we do we have to take
yeah let's give him a check first send
the king back to d8
yep then we can take on d7
force the queen trade and the king will
be forced to remain in the center
and we'll just start snagging all of his
pawns
but we'll also take a look at some other
moves after king game maybe we'll find a
faster win
there's no mate here directly bishop f6
gf6 doesn't quite cut the trick here
doesn't quite do the trick because again
queen f6 king c7 and i don't see the
continuation there
so in such a situation i wouldn't
reinvent the wheel
i would simply say okay we have three
minutes on the clock
maybe there's crazy moves like rook
takes e5 using all the pins
maybe just come back to e3 that's
another thing to consider but why
why is this necessary when we can just
win the knight his position is utterly
paralyzed
he won't be able to move his rook at the
end because we'll go rook to d8 check
and win the other rook
so we just take drop the bishop and
enjoy our life
thank you coder and i haven't if we
really wanted to be five fed about this
if we really wanted to squeeze the most
let's consider where the bishop would be
best placed in the long term now
at some point we want to move this rook
aside to pave the way for the other rook
piggies on the seventh one way that
occurs to me is to cover the seven
square with our bishop
and as you guys are pointing out i'm
pretty impressed this would not quite do
the trick although it's still possible
bishop all the way back to c1 so we
could swing it to a3
and pave the way for rookie seven how do
i find how do i know to look for this
well we have a choice of where to put
the bishop
you just gotta consider the long term
plan here what do you want to accomplish
well you know that you want to move the
circuit side and play rook d7 that's a
common pattern
and you know that e7 is a dark square we
have a dark sword bishop
just got to connect the dots here
always play bishop c1 yeah that's always
a nice move check
and our bishop participates in the
checkmating scheme which i really like
and rook d8 is made
that's really nice that's really really
nice magnus carlsen's team
has been vanquished boom
okay and we're 1500 on our 10-minute
speed run officially
all right
obviously it's easier with pins i'm not
pretending this is easy in the long
and just the grand scheme of things but
still i think that people are capable of
finding this if they put their mind to
it
that was really nice yeah no guys this
is gonna be the last game because i'm
i'm absolutely wiped
okay so
let's but let's analyze so we have an e5
and this is the cotton hour so bishop b5
bishop d7 again
okay if knight c6 then we take twice and
win
if knight b to d7 then knight f5 with
the same problem
that pawn is incredibly weak
bishop d7 we take first and then knight
f5 i mean you're welcome to bribe me i
i appreciate all the subs but this is
probably gonna be the last game
now i if i remember correctly the the
theory of this line goes queen takes d7
and after knight f5 those of you with
sharp tactical vision will notice
that black does have a tactic in this
position which may seem to
justify all of black's play what is it
knight takes c4 knight takes e4 and
this removes the defender from the
knight
and if knight takes c4 then well you can
get this and take on d6 and that's not
particularly impressive black will just
get his pieces out and attack the queen
but i have to update my own theoretical
knowledge
in such situations you look for
desperado sacrifices like if you're
already losing this knight
how can we give this knight away to make
the most damage to black's position and
then this comes to mind knight g7
and this really damages black's king
side d5
and now then i can move back to g3 and
then h5 i'm pretty sure this is a bad
position for black that's how the
theoretical line goes
so it's interesting some people play
like this with black
but if you know what you're doing you're
gonna get a good position but he takes
with a knight which i'm pretty sure is a
big mistake
because after nine at five now our
knight is permanently established here
or at least on a good square and again
if g6
then we go knight e3 this knight swings
around to this incredible
central outpost and if he develops his
bishop it's biting on granite which is
another reason why combining e5 and g6
is rarely a good idea
he should have done something like this
the game goes on it's not
over over but positionally it
essentially is
now what is the purpose of bishop b3 the
purpose is to stop knight b6 because
then we'll take with the bishop
and who can tell me on the basis of some
of the games i've already shown you
how should we meet knight f6 this
attempt to trade off the knights what
should white do thank you
m ramirez for the tier one
if you understand the positional
implications of this
now c4 is tempting but you guys are mis
misunderstanding the
the zen of this output it's the fact
that it's a knight that's particularly
important
this is fine you have an amazing
position here don't get me wrong
but what you really want is to keep this
knight on d5 the only way to do that is
to go bishop g5 that's the typical idea
trade the bishop for the knight and get
a very classic knight against bad bishop
position now you can play c4 to your
heart's content and double on the d
file but everybody should be able to see
the incredible domination that the
knight yields
not to men not to say that you know this
would be bad
this is a good bishop against that
bishop but i always like keeping a
knight on that outpost when possible
but if you can't then that's okay you
shouldn't despair
okay so anyways
in the game rook d8 happens we determine
intuitively that it's okay to sack the
pawn
we drop our knight on d5 again if
we take the rook instead automatically
it's a situation where
two pieces are hanging at the same time
and i always remind this to my students
if you have a situation where one of
your pieces is hanging one of your
opponent's pieces is saying you look for
two things you look for desperado
sacrifices
and you look for intermediate moves can
your opponent move the
his piece that's hanging and attack one
of your pieces that's a dangerous spot
to be in
because now your queen is attacked and
the bishop is attacked this is not great
thank you adam ramirez gifting to
pugsley
white's probably still better here
somehow but
why deal with this when you can just go
queen takes d5
and i read this in decision making
theory not chess related
but you know one of the key
like ideas when making a decision is to
consider whether you've
not omitted one of the options you may
think there are two options but
maybe there's a third and that often
happens when you go for something to win
material
your initial idea might have been to
take
on d8 and then you might start panicking
if you see knight c3 and like oh no i
made a mistake
but if you see the bigger picture here
you'll notice how much white's
dominating over black's pieces you're
only down to pawn
so it's basically a no brainer now if he
goes f6 then this is checkmate
he goes rick c8 we take the pawn
threaten checkmate
he has to defend it he weakens e6 bring
a rook and threatening mate
if he defends like this this comes in
boom boom is a fork and here's another
funny thing
yeah he should go king c8 here but now
we just take all of his pawns
why not why why the if rook because i
didn't want this rook to be dead weight
i didn't want
his queen to be tied to our rook in case
we have to move our rook at some point
i wanted to make sure that this rook
wouldn't be in the crosshairs of the
queen if that makes sense
boom boom he correctly goes queen b5 but
now we go rook d5 doubling with tempo
now if you went queen c6 an instructive
move here
what should white do who can
spot the correct continuation here would
like without this next move
everything would have fallen apart
yeah so you guys are quickly spotting
the correct idea which is to play rook
to d6
you have to make sure that you're
doubling with tempo
uh and to do that you you have to do
something about
the the queens now this move is very
fancy i'm
glad you spotted a cabin but black can
just take your bishop
right and if you go like this then rook
c7 comes black is holding things
together so
the simplest is to go rook d6 and then
with d1
in the game he lets us do this
immediately and now queen d6 sending the
king back and then trading
bishop c1 bishop a3 the final maneuver
resulting in checkmate that was a nice
game i think it was an instructive game
which featured both positional concepts
and tactical concepts and now you see
the importance if you play in the night
or
of not forgetting to play a6
um what classical games well there's a
book by irving chernov
old book called logical chess move by
move which is essentially a
compilation of important classical games
i would direct you to that to that book
which i've recommended to some students
before i haven't read it myself but
i know that it has a really really good
games you can also do a search on
chessgames.com
for classical games and uh
you know it'll give you a nice list that
you can analyze on your own
[Music]